recordemos que Benedicto renunció en
febrero de 2013 alegando que sus fuerzas
no eran suficientes para hacer el sumo
pontífice pero también el anuncio se dio
pocas semanas después de que se
revelaran los llamados batilix que
mostraban una disputa de poder dentro de
la iglesia cuéntenos qué revelaron los
batilix Y cómo impactó esto a Benedicto
impactó directamente muy buenos días
impacto directamente al papa
tan así que lo lleva a renunciar Y por
qué impacta directamente porque hay dos
elementos los vatican tics la relación
que tiene el Vaticano con el tema de la
mafia por lo tanto Cómo se manejaban los
recursos siempre he dicho que la
renuncia del Papa es por el tema de los
abusos sexuales dentro de la Iglesia
Católica pero también por el tema de los
dineros Cómo se manejaban los dineros
durante mucho tiempo en el banco
Vaticano por tanto estos dos elementos
son los que llevan a que el papa
renuncie Y a propósito de los escándalos
de abuso sexual
otra polémica que golpeó al papa emérito
y fue la investigación de la Iglesia
Católica Romana de Munich sobre casos de
abuso sexual entre 1945 y 2019 que decía
ese informe concretamente sobre
Benedicto Y cómo reaccionó el papa
emérito son 497 las víctimas en 74 años
de investigación que se llevan a cabo en
Múnich y efectivamente plantea que hay
cuatro casos en donde el papa habría
sido un encubridor que habría sabido de
todos los elementos que sucedieron ahí y
el como arzobispo no habría hecho lo que
tenía que hacer más aún habría dado la
orden de trasladar al sacerdote de un
lugar a otro que era la práctica que
durante en varias ollas obispados a
nivel internacional se ha llevado a cabo
eso lo que dice directamente a él lo que
él dijo con respecto a eso es que él
tenía conocimiento del tema pero que
efectivamente no es ningún incubridor
Esa fue su respuesta pero esa respuesta
queda abierta a leer las investigaciones
que siguen su curso y cuál es la huella
según ustedes deja Benedicto en la
iglesia católica especialmente en las
visiones con las que discrepó con el
Papa Francisco
bueno el discrepaba en varias cosas
primero el Papa Benedicto era un hombre
bastante conservador frente a temas como
el aborto la eutanasia el matrimonio
homosexual Pero además de eso el Papa
Benedicto al ser un intelectual yo estoy
muy seguro y creo que la historia lo va
a recordar Así que es decir las cosas
sobre el papel es muy distinta a
hacerlas yo creo que Francisco es un
hombre que ha hecho las cosas de acuerdo
Benedicto renuncia no tiene fuerzas para
poder enfrentar de acuerdo pero
Francisco sí ha sido capaz de poder
adentrarse en todos estos problemas se
le va a recordar como un hombre un gran
intelectual pero un hombre que no pudo
no pudo avanzar en todos los procesos
que existen dentro de la Iglesia
Católica problemas estructurales y
sistémicos y muy brevemente qué ha
pasado entonces con la iglesia en medio
de estos escándalos y cómo se han
enfrentado
Bueno lo que ha pasado con respecto a la
iglesia hoy en día es que siguen los
problemas dentro de la iglesia siguen
las investigaciones en diferentes
diócesis y diócesis a nivel mundial
seguimos revisando hace muy poco nomás
salió el caso francesa sino el caso
alemán en el caso latinoamericano
tenemos el caso chileno por lo tanto hay
varios problemas que hay dentro y que se
siguen investigando con respecto al tema
eclesiástico yo sinceramente creo que la
iglesia tiene un problema sistémico y un
problema estructural y ese es el gran
problema que hoy día tiene el Papa
Francisco y está enfrentando